september 2020 deutschland im lockdown
doch es ist noch warm draußen und viele
jugendliche feiern im freien illegale
corona partys so wie hier im hamburger
stadtpark
jugendliche umgehen die kontakt
beschränkungen wollen einfach spaß haben
und feiern immer wieder eskalieren
solche partys auch es kommt zu exzessen
schlägereien und polizeieinsätzen am 19
september dann passiert aber etwas
monströses am rande so einer party wird
ein 15-jähriges mädchen opfer einer
massenvergewaltigung
bild liegen jetzt exklusive
informationen aus dieser nacht vor und
die sind einfach nur erschütternd
schauen wir noch mal auf die fakten was
wissen wir über den fall das opfer ist
ein 15-jähriges mädchen es gibt elf
beschuldigte im alter zwischen 17 und 21
und der tatort wir haben es eben schon
gehört war der hamburger stadtpark geht
um den vorwurf der vergewaltigung und
sexuellen missbrauchs über zwei stunden
lang ein verdächtiger filmte die tat
auch nur ein verdächtiger ist aber
bislang in u-haft zwei verdächtige sind
zwillinge und die staatsanwaltschaft
hamburg erhebt unter anderem anklage
wegen gemeinschaftlicher vergewaltigung
bild-reporter charly walter ist vor ort
an der stelle an der es zu dieser
unfassbaren tat gekommen ist charlie du
bist an diesem tatort und es gibt neue
informationen ganz aktuell heute morgen
zu den tatverdächtigen
ja guten morgen aus hamburg das stimmt
wir haben gerade erfahren dass die elf
verdächtigen alle auf freiem fuß sind es
lag gegen einen ein haftbefehl vor der
wurde jetzt vom haftrichter aufgehoben
also wer am 11 mutmaßlicher
vergewaltiger die alle frei sind und
durch die stadt laufen wie kommt man
denn auf die zahl 11 gibt es da
irgendwelche indizien
ja ich kann mal einmal für euch den
tathergang nacherzählen ich bin ja jetzt
im hamburger stadtpark hinter mir seht
ihr die große festwiese das ist der
bereich wo im sommer 2020 rund 20 21
wild gefeiert wurde weil die bars und
clubs geschlossen waren und direkt
nebenan liegt der tatort wir gehen jetzt
einmal rüber ins gebüsch es ist wirklich
direkt am weg gelegen
und das ist die stelle wo diese
abscheuliche start-up abscheuliche tat
ist tschuldigung stattgefunden haben
soll das ist eine tat die selbst
erfahrene polizeireporter schockiert
also meine kollegen hier in hamburg noel
altendorf und marco zitzow haben gestern
als erste diesen tathergang erfahren und
selbst jeden fehlten die worte also in
diesem gebiet hier wie man sieht nah am
weg hier sollen elf junge männer sich
nacheinander über die junge frau über
das mädchen her gemacht haben über
dieses 15 jährige mädchen das war so
gegen 23 uhr in der nacht vom 19 auf den
20 september der erste der täter soll
das mädchen das gerade von einer
geburtstagsfeier kam hier eingeloggt
haben und sie dann als erster
vergewaltigt haben danach haben die elf
jungs nacheinander über einen zeitraum
von zweieinhalb stunden dieses mädchen
immer wieder vergewaltigt einer das hat
das geschehen auch gefilmt die polizei
hat über ein jahr lang ermittelt hat
hunderte zeugen befragt oder mehr als
100 zeugen hat hier im gebüsch auf dem
boden rings um zahlreiche spuren
gesichert es gab hausdurchsuchungen es
wurden handys beschlagnahmt es wurden
nachrichten ausgewertet und so kam man
eben auf diese elf verdächtigen das ist
der hamburger stadtpark ich kenne ihn
auch ganz gut es ist sehr öffentlich
dort gehen tag und nacht wirklich
menschen entlang warum hat das niemand
mitbekommen
warum niemand das mitbekommen hat und
warum niemand eingegriffen ist das
wissen wir nicht genau ich kann
allerdings selber hier im stadtpark ich
war selber auf der festwiese hier hinter
mir im letzten sommer hat hier berichtet
als es die randale gab es zwischen
polizei und jugendlichen heißt es die
flaschenwürfe gab als ist die
böllerwürfe gab und ich habe mitbekommen
was das für eine 5v ist was sich hier
trifft also das waren jugendliche nicht
alle aber schon sehr viele die waren
wirklich auf randale aus die wollten
nicht nur was erleben sondern die
wollten stress haben mit der polizei und
die wollten einen bereich in dem keine
regeln gelten und ich nehme mal an dass
das auch zu einer zeit passiert ist wo
sich hier eben solche leute getummelt
haben und vielleicht alle so besoffen
oder so drauf dass ich nicht gemerkt
haben oder sie haben es vielleicht noch
unterstützt ich weiß es nicht genau aber
ich könnte es mir so erklären
was weißt du über die tatverdächtigen
die ja jetzt alle wieder auf freiem fuß
sind
ja über die elf jungen männer ist soweit
oder nach unseren informationen sind die
alle zwischen 17 und 21 jahre alt zum
tatzeitpunkt waren alle unter 21 sie
arbeiten teilweise also einige haben
jobs sogar teilweise im karitativen
bereich nach unseren informationen
und sie haben fünf davon haben eine
ausländische staatsbürgerschaft also ist
ein pole dabei ein liga ein ägypter
vielmehr wissen wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt aber noch nicht also ob sie
sich vorher kannten ob sie sich
abgesprochen haben das wissen wir noch
nicht klar ist zwei von ihnen sind
zwillinge also brüder das wissen wir
bislang weißt du wie es dem mädchen
heute geht ein jahr nach dieser
schrecklichen tat
wir wissen nicht wie es dem mädchen geht
wir haben keinen kontakt zu dem mädchen
wir werden auch nicht versuchen kontakt
zu dem mädchen aufzunehmen weil es genug
gelitten hat was wir jetzt wissen zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt ist dass sie von
gynäkologen und rechtsmedizinern
untersucht wurde es wurden auch an ihren
neuen verschiedene dna spuren gefunden
also neuen spermaspuren man mag es kaum
sagen aber es ist leider so und
man kann davon ausgehen dass dieses
mädchen in therapeutischer behandlung
ist das ist ja in solchen fällen immer
so also wenn die denn der fall der
polizei bei den behörden bekannt ist
dann wird dieses mädchen auch betreut
letzte frage noch gibt es keine
begründung dafür warum alle auf freiem
fuß sind alle tatverdächtigen muss man
sagen dass gilt die unschuldsvermutung
die begründung kennen wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht also es wird wohl
so sein dass die haftrichter oder die
staatsanwaltschaft keinen dringenden
haftgrund erkannt haben also es gibt
dann wenn die staatsanwaltschaft sagt
dass es keine dringende keine
fluchtgefahr oder verdunkelungsgefahr
gibt dann kann es eben sein dass die
verdächtigen auch wenn dringende benson
dringenden tatverdacht gibt es die dann
eben auf freiem fuß sind